Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. This is Radiolab.
Today we have part two of a three part series that we're calling in the no,
no, as in no, we were inspired to do this, uh,
after hearing a set of stories on a show called the heart produced by Caitlin
press last week. We played excerpts of that series. And if you haven't heard,
uh, last week's episode,
I would encourage you to go back and listen because the, uh,
stories that Katelyn told, uh, which got some very intense, uh,
reactions from our listeners online all over the map, however you feel, I mean,
those stories that she made are a very striking personal view of consent from
the inside.
Now it just so happens that Katelyn produced those stories in the spring of
2017, which is the spring,
just before all the accusations started hitting the news, um,
first against Harvey Weinstein and then congressmen like Al Franken,
actors like Kevin Spacey and then Comedians. And then in many cases,
the very people,
very men who were reporting about those stories and much of what made it into
the news was pretty clear cut,
like criminal cases or accusations of clear breaches of consent.
But then we started to hear about the cases that were harder,
not explicitly criminal, more nuanced.
And that gray zone, which Katelyn was, was, uh,
in many ways exploring in her piece. It occurred to us like,
this is a conversation we're all trying to have right now.
So what we started doing in the wake of listening to her stories was doing a
series of interviews of our own with people all over the map who are thinking
and rethinking consent in interesting ways.
We'll play a couple over the next two weeks,
but we ran into one particular interview. Let's see
if it's working. Katelyn, you there? Yes, I'm here. Hey, I did it. You did it.
Did we
not stop thinking about, in fact,
it created a lot of really difficult conversations internally.
And uh,
so we just kind of decided why don't we play this thing relatively raw,
which we don't do very often.
But let's just put it out more or less how it happened and all of its flaws.
Caitlin, Caitlin, can you hear Hannah? Yes, it's sal. It's Hannah.
Hannah. Okay. Sorry. Yeah. Caitlin, could you hear it? Hona I'm speaking.
Can you hear me? Yes, I can hear you. Okay, sweet. Thanks for coming in,
both of you guys. Thank you. Really glad to be here. Okay. So, uh,
since I've already pronounced your name and correctly,
can you tell me who you are and how to say your name and what you do? Sure.
My name is Hannah Startland. I'm an independent consultant. I work on,
sorry,
I'm an independent educational consultant and I specialize in educational crisis
management
and we, uh,
call upon him because she has a very particular vantage point on this whole set
of questions.
When I see a unfamiliar number from a distant area code on my phone,
um, if I can, I pick that up and it happens quite regularly there.
I pick it up and I just hear sobbing, hmm,
that's a mom whose kid just got expelled. So that happens regularly,
like daily, weekly, more like once or twice a month.
Often the calls are coming from moms whose sons have been accused of some kind
of sexual misconduct.
I got my first two calls on that topic in January of 2014 and since then it's
grown and grown and grown. And about a third of my work now, um,
is students who are involved with a title nine in one way or another.
Title nine is a federal law that deals with, among other things, uh,
sexual harassment, sexual violence on college campuses.
What Hannah will do when she gets these calls is she'll work with these young
men who've been accused to get them back into school,
either the school they were in,
but more often it means transferring to a different school.
So families hire me to help their kids get into college or Grad school.
Usually.
I think it is a good thing when people in general,
even people who may have done something very bad, um,
who want education can continue to get education.
Yeah.
Um, as long as they're seeking it, honestly. But what if you,
but what if you're then just deferring the problem to some other campus? I mean,
like, let's say there's a guy who, uh,
that's victimized somebody and then you help them get to another college where
maybe they do it again. Well, they,
they'd be in the community one way or another.
And I think this is an area where I see a lot of problems with,
um, classism, uh,
and probably racism to where we're,
we're so concerned about that accused person being on another college campus.
If he isn't on a college campus, where do you think he's going to be?
Cause he's not going to jail. Hmm. Um, the students that we're talking about,
typically the police don't even get called, but if they do,
they come and see the evidence and say, this evidence is so thin.
You know, we're not, we're not even gonna impose charges. Um,
so say, you know, okay, well he's not going to college anymore.
He's going to work at McDonald's.
And so if there's a risk to the fellow people at McDonald's,
then we just don't care because they're not the upper middle class white women
who were actually worried about on the college campuses.
And I have misgivings about the ideas at the,
the college students are special need that community needs special attention
that other young adults don't need. So you're,
I just so that I know that I have your point of view that I understand it.
It's that you don't,
it's not that you don't think that some people should be expelled sometimes.
Oh, sure. They show that. Yeah. Okay. But, um,
I feel very comfortable with the idea that people who want to continue their
education ought to be able to make their case for why they want to continue it.
What I do is help them talk about what happened.
So if you're interested in covering it up or hiding it,
there's no reason to hire me. Um,
I help you have that hard conversation or write that difficult essay about what
went wrong. Even if you feel you were wrongly accused,
you were railroaded by the school, um,
you better find unwise choices that you made selfish choices that you made.
There are not a lot of these cases where I think while you handled everything
perfectly, you didn't make any risk preferring choices.
There's nothing you could change to keep this from happening to you in the
future.
You still have to tell a story about mistakes that you made and how you're
working to fix them. How does that go? I mean,
do you find that people will maintain that?
Like will they sort of hold onto the idea that they did have consent even if the
other person says that they didn't? Certainly,
and I'm not trying to chase people,
I'm not necessarily trying to change their mind about whether they had consent
that, I mean they were there and I was not trusting. Do you see in a,
in a scenario where you have both sides of the story,
what's the usual difference? It depends.
There's a few cases where the stories just are incompatible. Um,
but there are, most of my cases,
the dispute is narrow.
Everybody agrees that the encounter was generally consensual,
but either the consent to all of it was withdrawn or uh,
you know,
according to the accuser or there was consents to ax a and B but not c and c
just happened before they knew it and there wasn't a conversation about it.
And um,
w the one party feels that c was a rape or that,
no, I agree.
I acted like I wanted this the whole time and maybe even I said yes,
but in retrospect I was too drunk or high. Um,
and that that consent was no good.
It nullifies the consent at this point in the conversation we talked a little
bit about like the different kinds of consent,
what works like affirmative consent, where it's about clear permission,
often verbal permission that can be withdrawn at any time,
which Hannah says she is all 4000%. The question is if you don't do it,
is it rape?
And that's the dichotomy that I object to or am a skeptic about, I should say.
I mean if, if, again, if people can show me that this works and I'm interested,
but when you say it, I guess that's the thing,
like when you say if people can show me if this works, um,
can you sort of unpack what you mean by that? Like he let me just,
it seems so clear to me that it does work. I don't know. So let me tell you,
let me tell you if my experience, so I'm just sort of curious.
Let me tell you a few stories. Um,
there's a couple that I can give more identifying information about because this
case is in litigation now.
And so that's on the public record and the fact that I'm involved in the cases
on the public record, so I, I can say a few more things. So I had a student, um,
he in a girl wearing his room, um, after a party,
they didn't know each other well.
He touched her private parts and there was vaginal penetration with his fingers.
Both parties agree that he asked for and got affirmative verbal consent.
He said, do you like this? And she said yes. And she faked an orgasm.
Both port parties are telling the exact same story.
And he was found responsible for sexual assault. Cause she said,
I didn't mean it. I said yes, I was enjoying it. Um,
in order to get it over with faster. Um,
I wanted a graceful way to leave his room and I thought I'm making him think I
was having an orgasm would would help me get out of there more gracefully
without being rude. Um,
and he was suspended for two and a half years. I let you finish.
I'll let you finish and then I'll say what I think. I just, no, I mean,
so yeah, I mean that's, that's what I'm seeing in practice. You know,
it's, it's other, other cases that I've seen, um,
is someone who basically the, the my, my student is a big black guy,
you know, well over six feet tall, a lot of muscles. He's an athlete. Um,
and it's undisputed that that uh,
he and the accuser were in her dorm room together to hook up.
Um,
they took off all their clothes and she touched his genitals and performed oral
sex on him.
And she said that, um,
she did that because she was fearful once they were both naked.
Um, and she felt that
the situation was so overwhelming that she had to,
um, reach out and touch him and then reach out and use her mouth on him.
Um, and the, the school decided in that situation, um,
that the only thing that had gone wrong was that there wasn't a verbal
confirmation.
And so if you go in somebody's dorm room,
you take and both of you take off your clothes and she touches you in places,
your penis in her mouth when you're not speaking,
she has not conveyed consent. Hmm.
Which I think [inaudible] I think, yeah. Yeah. I guess from my,
from my point of view, it's like the rules are,
are set up in a way that, that kind of protect, um,
the person who feels violated.
Like I, I guess to me,
I agree there's a different type of person who feels violated difference,
which like, I mean, sorry. Oh, well,
we're not supposed to be concerned about who feels violated.
We're supposed to be concerned about who was violated.
Yeah.
Yeah. But I mean, I, I guess
the person who was violated, I mean, if they feel violated,
then I would argue that they are, they were violated. So, you know,
if they feel violated. I guess what I'm saying is that like,
I think that having affirmative consent be a rule that's, that's,
that's followed and taken seriously when it comes to like legal stuff. It just,
it protects that ambiguity.
People should go to jail for not getting the verbal. Yes.
Um, well, I mean, I talked about definitely complicated.
What I think it's complicated, but I think that it, it, it,
it makes it so that the person who was violated feels violated,
is the one who is always protected and who's the one who's always in the right.
And I think that that's a good thing.
Yeah. I don't agree with you about that. You know what I think?
I don't think they're always in the room.
I don't think they're always in the right [inaudible]
I don't think they're always in the right,
but I think that it's safer to assume that they're always in the right. Well,
you know, there's going to be a very small margin of people who are not,
but I feel like it's important to.
But how do we know? That's just my point of view. First of all,
how do we know how small that merging is? I don't know how small it is.
I mean, I, I'm thinking to, um,
various various encounters that my students have had, for example, where, um,
is they both agreed that they were having consensual intercourse and they both
agree that the consent was withdrawn during the intercourse and that the
intercourse stopped. The dispute is about how rapidly it stopped.
Hmm. Um, and so, and, and there isn't,
you know, in that case, I, I just, I just hesitate to say,
and, and again, it's, it seems clear on paper that the absolutes of that, well,
you control your body the second you convey, um,
for example, um, start to cry during sex. All right,
well then, okay.
I would assume non-verbally that this should stop or, you know,
we should make sure, and it did stop, but, you know,
did that take two seconds, five seconds, 30 seconds.
Um, and that from, from the, the moment of
theirs, is it problem? The other problem is there's no, you know,
what should you reasonably be aware of. And,
and I I'm very uncomfortable with the idea that person A's feelings determine
whether person B's behavior was rape or not.
Because always calling it rape. I mean sometimes sexual assaults,
it's called sexual assault, you know, sexual assault.
I feel like that's a really important distinction that like the terms even
sexual assault is not, it is not adequate, you know,
because there are so many different great gradations. Yeah, absolutely.
I don't think, I don't, I don't think like, I don't think I personally I do,
I do think that if someone is,
someone's feelings should determine whether person B has assaulted them.
You know,
like I think even thinking about like when someone cries in the middle of sex,
you know, like talking about talking about like the is it, is it five seconds,
is it 10 seconds, is it 30 seconds?
Like what are all the things that happened leading up to that moment?
Well cause he is, he disputes. He says,
I stopped as soon as I realized she was crying. Yeah.
And she says that she says I was,
I was crying for like 25 seconds, let's say 30 seconds.
And so that period between when I started crying and when he realized I was
crying, but he wouldn't, my says he realized he, but I feel like,
to me when I hear a story like that,
I think that there was actually a lot of other,
there were probably a lot of other things leading up to that moment that we're
not perceived, you know,
or that the reason why she's coming forward and saying that this was an assault,
this was a violation. There's probably a lot, there's a,
a much an unseen architecture to, to that,
to that story. Um, that is really complicated I guess. Like,
I don't think that someone would just come out and be like,
I cried for 30 seconds and then, and you didn't, you didn't stop. Like,
it's probably a lot. It goes, it runs much deeper than that.
There was something, there's something unnameable happening in that room.
Um,
and she sort of hinges that unnameable feeling of violation on this grain if
they feel seems trivial when you talk about it out loud. Um,
but she's trying to say something was not right here, you know. I agree.
Um, yeah, so I, I very much agreed with it. It's just, it's complicated.
I'm sort of just trying to get into the complicated area of it. Right. Um,
I think dairy, we agree on a whole lot that, um, uh,
I don't dispute at all. Um, I see even in,
even in my cases where I have the most doubt about what happened, um,
I don't dispute that the accuser feels violated. I think, I think that's true.
Um, they usually convince him. They usually convince feels violated.
She is violated
because there's all kinds of reasons besides being sexually assaulted that a
person might feel violated.
Um, so, I mean, I'll, I'll,
I'll talk about one instance for myself. Um,
you know,
w w the people who have broken my heart when I was in love with people.
Um, and, you know, there was a breakup where I got treated like dirt,
uh, when we were in love and like knew each other's families and all of that.
And then, you know,
basically ghosted me and then dumped me an phone call 10 months in.
Um, I felt extremely violated.
I can't put into words how bad he made me feel. Um,
you know, and,
and how it colored my memory of every interaction we'd had for 10 months and
Christmas together with my family in Hawaii, you know, and,
and calling into question, you know, did, was he lying to me then?
Um, I just, I, I feel very violated by his actions. Um,
it's probably not a word I would have come up with. Um,
but I feel unbelievably, you know,
I'm happy and married now. It's all good. Um, you know, I,
I should not have ended up with him. Um, but especially at the time,
I mean that, that was an experience that permanently changed me.
I'm not the same person I was before that hurt rake,
and he didn't sexually assault me. You know, this, this,
it was, it was awful. What he did.
And I,
it just makes sense to me that people could be unbelievably deeply hurt by all
kinds of behavior that isn't sexual assault.
That I, I can see, I can see that. I can see, I can see,
I can see that. But I, I guess I feel like, um, you know,
what we're doing right now is working against history. You know, like,
I think that we're trying to make progress on,
on this issue of sexual assault and the much larger issue of the imbalance of
power as it is distributed between the genders. Like,
can you ever really as a woman, and this is,
I don't know if I fully agree with what I'm about to say, but it's just,
I'm just posing it as a, as a philosophical question. Um,
you know, if you're,
if you're taught from birth to define your pleasure based on someone else and
someone else's pleasure,
how can you even know what you want or don't want in those private moments,
you know? And like, how do we restore that balance? You know,
I think a lot of what you're describing is on a,
what I'm seeing as a general, as a generational divide, um,
in, in feminism. I don't know how old you are. I'm 42. Yeah. I'm, I'm,
I'm 30. Yeah. Yeah. Women who are my age and older,
um, I find,
I tend to agree with me and the women who are college age are in their twenties
now often don't. And um, the disconnect stems,
I feel like when you were describing how,
because of societal pressures and training from birth and all that,
when the man was naked in my room,
I could not do anything but give him a blow job.
I could not say no. And I would say you did not say no.
And there may be situations,
um, where we agree that this is a can't situation,
but I don't see it as a hostage for my feminism.
Mm. That's just helpless there. She has no agency.
They put her in a pink dress and now she has to give a blow job. Yeah,
I understand that. And I think that's a really important point of view.
But I also, I guess people have done research about that. The,
the fact that like young girls define how good sex was based on how much they
perceived the other person enjoying it and, and,
and even something as simple as that creates a power dynamic. And I,
I feel like I'm not really seeing the men and the men that I know,
the young men that I know,
I'm not seeing them understanding the power that they have that's really easy
to, to, to abuse, you know, and like how do you fix that?
That's what it kind of all comes down to. And like there has to be there what,
there has to be some kind of consequences if we're going to see it change.
[inaudible]
we're going to take a quick break and we'll come right back to a,
this conversation between Kaitlin [inaudible] and myself. Just a moment.
Hello, my name is Aaron Davies. I'm calling from Tempe, Arizona.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
there are doors that once opened, can never be closed.
WYC studios and step judge with underground layer spooked.
Season two is here.
Listen now every week it's all Halloween.
Be Afraid, but don't turn out the lights,
listen to speak wherever you get your podcasts.
I'm Jad Abumrad this is Radiolab.
We're back with the second episode and a three part series that we're doing. Uh,
inspired by collaboration with Katelyn pressed.
It's called in the know and a,
we're going to jump back into the conversation that Kaitlin and I were having
with Hanta Startland. But before we do a,
I want to bring in some other voices cause I'm where you're sitting and with
purchase place cause that way I can just like swoop as we were working on this
series a, I mean it really wasn't exploration for us.
One of the things that happened along the way is we convene groups of college
students in different spots across the country. If we,
if there are groups of uh, college shakes, men and women. Uh, I was with a man,
my colleagues, Becca Bressler and she, my only, I are with women.
We're going to hear more from the women next week. Uh, the only play,
which is a bit of the men because when Hannah and Caitlin and I were talking a,
it called to mind something that I heard a lot in these conversations,
you have to take a leap.
At some point you have to take it like you're talking to this person,
you're making eye contact or whatever and like, yeah,
you can ask like can I kiss you?
And like they say yes but like at the same time sometimes you just go for it and
like that's where it gets iffy because like whether like sacrificing that is
what we need to do for no one to get raped or no one's getting raped in these
non super malicious scenarios. Like,
maybe what we have to give up is just you're looking at your eyes,
the sun's rising, you're like, hello, would you like,
can I record you on my cell phone of you saying you're down to make out right
now? You know? I mean, and as I say, you know,
that's something I guess I'm willing to give up if that's what's being asked and
if that actually solves the issue.
But I just think that we're coming to a point where that might be the line,
by the way, the, the,
the thing he's talking about that is actually an app that exists.
We talked to the guy who made it, but what he,
what he and other guys were saying was that they're uneasy.
They still feel somehow caught between those old gendered expectation that it's
the man's job to pursue and a, the world that we're in now,
which seems to not want that, but maybe not entirely, not,
not want that. They're not sure.
And a lot of them worry that maybe they've already crossed the line without
knowing it.
It's always in the back of my mind,
like I've hooked up with a girl that's like instigated it.
Like I'm like while having sex,
she decides that like she doesn't want to do like she was going to go home and
gets up, please. Okay. You know like then what?
Then if if the next day she decides that or she realizes that they like,
but she didn't want to do that. Maybe after the fact,
then it just be my truth versus hers.
I've definitely hooked up with people where they were very drunk.
It was the first time we talked up, no one ever was like,
oh that was not okay or anything. But in all those situations,
I guarantee based on myself,
I was drunker than the person I was hooking up with.
But because I'm a man that could be retrospectively,
that could have been sexual assault. You know? And I, and I,
that's definitely the biggest question I've given myself post this thing is
like, wow, could it even be claimed?
Like I don't think that I sexually assaulted someone at all.
I mean a given that, you know,
one I asked her are you sure but you that isn't even enough cause let's say
alcohol, you know even if you get a vocal consent, if there's alcohol involved.
So I guess that's where it gets interesting.
I mean not interesting not to make it cold,
but yeah we would've to though even if even if the end of that you didn't make a
mistake as someone's like that wasn't okay what you did yesterday or something.
Right. You say your side, I'd be like, Yo,
I really need to understand that you don't like you learn like we don't have to
be, I don't think like be free, like be a good person. I understand that.
But if somebody says like you sexually assaulted me and if it's a situation like
you're talking about where you both have been drunk and you say, I'm sorry,
is that not,
I would be scared to say that because it's here to say what,
I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
Because that's like you're admitting you're guilty even if you don't think you
are, if you try to engage in a conversation like that.
So just maybe like you don't say, I'm sorry you say oh my God,
like please explain to me like how I did that or like what happened cause I was
too drunk to even remember or like something. Yeah it's its,
it's not about being like a second
and after, you know, after having, after,
after listening to these guys and then having this conversation with Katelyn and
Kauna. I mean for,
for one the things that they were afraid of were exactly the things that we were
talking about.
In two I started to think about the fear that sort of ambient fear that was
always in the room in it's sort of a different way. It couldn't,
you argue there's something useful about the fear because that fear
might push these guys to address exactly what Katelyn was just saying.
It might push the guys to, you know what I mean? What, what, what I,
what I hear over and over again when I talk to him when I talked to students is
that the women in, in, in a,
in a sexual encounter are thinking about 12 things and the guys are thinking
about one thing, which is themselves, right? They're just,
they're not reading the room. They're not reading their partner.
What's gonna change that if not fear,
like the fear that these guys feel right now could actually make them start to
pay attention. Make us, I should say start to pay attention.
Yes. It might.
I certainly think of my essay writing support as a form of education,
coaching, how a student's should handle a tough situation.
Um,
I'm not sure that making the consequence really bad is what makes it more likely
that the behavior will change.
But I would love to see, uh,
young men encouraged to go through the kind of,
um,
analysis of their actions that a mind do with me.
And, and it's, I think it's a really positive process for them. And,
and I see what looks to me like greater insight.
Hmm. Can I can, I want to bring it back to the moment itself,
because a lot of what we're talking about on a macro level,
okay.
Uh, still has to be negotiated in these moments. Right? And you've talked about,
um, the idea of, of we need a reasonableness standard for,
for the consensual moment. So what does that mean to you?
So to me it means that, um,
okay,
communication needs to be in a shared language. You know, if,
if someone says to me in Russian, that doesn't feel good,
I just don't speak that.
So is it reasonable to expect me to understand, um,
what this person was conveying in a language that I don't speak? Um,
like I would consider crying to be a universal language. Now, if,
if it's dark and you're not touching the person's face, whatever,
you might not realize immediately that they are,
um, crying without, you know, it's not wow. Walk, type, crying. Um, it's just,
it's tears and, and, and emotion and clenched throat and all that. Um,
how rapidly is it reasonable to expect that you perceive that communication,
which is communication? And if you could see the person's face,
and I'd say it's a very unambiguous communication. Um,
is it reasonable to think it might take you a minute
to, to realize that the,
this my partner's feelings are totally changed. So there's,
there's a spectrum between saying no, no, no,
stop and expecting somebody to read your mind, right?
That there's a million different ways to convey that with different levels of
urgency and clarity. And I just think we should,
we should take into account what can we reasonably expect him in this scenario
to realize about her changed frame of mind.
Caitlin, what do you think?
For me,
I think a step forward is just being aware of the power dynamics that are
happening in sex. Talking about them explicitly, understanding what they are,
understanding the ways that they're fun, the ways that they're pleasurable and,
and being really open about those things.
And I think that like it all, it all comes back to communication.
I mean like I really liked what you said, Hannah, about the,
about the languages, you know, figuring out how to speak each other's languages,
figuring out trust. Um,
and also just like having there be less of a stigma around conversations,
explicit, open, totally shameless conversations about sexuality,
um, would bring us forward and in, in massive, massive leaps around this stuff.
And also just that like that. Like, I mean,
I think the thing that I'm not seeing that I wish I did see was just giving a
shit, you
know, like Karen, like having had it, like, you know, when somebody says, Hey,
that, that experience sucked for me. Having the other person be like, wow,
let's talk about it. Are you okay? You know, it's like,
I feel like so many situations would be, would be,
would be solved if that was the dynamic as opposed to,
what are you talking about? Like, um, the gas, lighting, all that stuff. Anyway,
that's my list. Yeah.
The work I do with some of the students. Um, when I say,
so what do you regret? Um, and sometimes they're not sure. They were like,
I really didn't attack her. And I said, but do you regret?
Is it ever your goal to get into your bed with someone and have them walking
away going, Oh, I'm glad that's over. And the guys are like, no,
I don't want that. And I was like,
well that's what you got and we can dispute.
We can dispute whether it was an assault or not. It is objective Lee,
the case that this person had a bad experience with you.
Everybody agrees on that and if that wasn't what you wanted to happen,
then you probably have regret about that.
I should have done something differently. So it didn't come out that way.
I'm not telling them what they ought to want sexually,
but I do tell them to consider what they want sexually.
It is, it is not a, I want to preface this by saying,
I'm not saying that the training of men and women is symmetrical. It's not.
But that some of them may may realize some of the men may realize,
you know what, I was told that men are supposed to like any,
any kind of sexual contact we can get from anyone anywhere.
We're supposed to be happy about that.
And is that actually what I want or is that what people expect me to want?
And maybe I would prefer more of a, you know, loving,
gentle, a kind of relationship.
Maybe I'm a man and not that kind of model would actually work better for me
than this conquest model.
And it's interesting cause I mean what I hear a lot coming out of the me too
movement is that a,
I hear a lot of women saying guys you need to do the work. Okay.
Like this is, this is largely your work to do right now. Um,
and I hadn't expected to hear you talking about what you do as in subsets being
a part of that. Like you are actually,
it seems involved in some of the guys doing the work.
I mean like how to do the work is it's own sort of can of worms like who we are,
which is something we haven't really talked too much about.
But it is interesting to hear that I wasn't expecting that to be the case.
Like it's
that it's not necessarily my goal,
but it may be necessary in order to achieve my goal,
which is to help you advocate for your education.
You can't do that effectively unless you've been thoughtful about your past.
Hmm. Um, and my,
my thesis is grey help the kids see the gray
and you know, this is, this is not a binary world we live in,
in terms of gender, in terms of communication. Uh, and,
and to some extent I feel like we have to work with the complexity of what's in
front of us and even if we wish it were black and white and that would make our
job a lot easier. Yeah. Caitlin, any final thoughts?
Hey Man. No, I don't think so. I guess.
Um, yeah, this has been really great and Combo. Loved it.
[inaudible]
okay.
You want to think Caitlyn crest and haunted Dotlan for sitting down to talk a
few notes before we close. If you have experienced sexual assault,
there are resources out there to support you and the national sexual assault
hotline at 1-800-SIX-FIVE, six.
Hope that is (800) 656-4673 can provide support and connect you to resources in
your local area. And also, one thing I do want to add
is that this conversation,
the reason we aired it without a ton of edits and amendments,
is that this was not meant to be a comprehensive take on anything.
This is one small piece of a Muslim larger conversation. If anything,
this was simply an attempt to hold a space for that continuing conversation
space where we can talk about this stuff,
which we're going to continue to do next week and next week we'll end up in a
place where that conversation happens very explicitly and very differently.
For better or worse. In this episode,
we had production help from Rachel Q sick research and reporting help from Becca
Bressler and Shimon [inaudible]. I'm Jad Abumrad. Thanks for listening.